on this episode we talk about title
instagrams evolution we also talk about
QR codes and Star Wars versus Star Trek
you ask questions and I answer them this
is the askgaryvee show
do you want to get a Cameron gets like
some content like meaning either either
angle video content or just pictures for
like stock stuff let's go into it while
we got him out of there so then he has
to walk in for the show and don't edit
any of this right from the beginning
where I told them to get some content
maybe a donation everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is episode 92 of
the askgaryvee show episode 92 I love
the number 92 because one of my favorite
all-time Jets Shaun Ellis more than
number 92 and when I think of Shaun
Ellis I think about the great 2000 Draft
where we got Lavernia Scholz and Chad
Pennington and John Abraham and Shaun
Ellis which became the foundation of the
Jets solid run in the early 2000s and so
what makes that happy and exciting for
me is that obviously they just just had
their giraffe as a matter fact maybe we
should edit some of the content in I'm
over here I'm over here I know was funny
that you kid but maybe we should kid
d-roc there's some footage like some
like
and I think that just just had the best
draft they've had since I've been a fan
I'm a static within your cadets draft
this year and I want to welcome all the
youngsters to the Jets team um what else
I had a great weekend it was my mom's
60th birthday big shout out to tomorrow
Vaynerchuk that was super fun it's been
a lot of time with the kids the big
fight they're just really nice the
weather on the East Coast weather is
insanity played some basketball this
morning was a lot of fun India weird
India let's get into the show dan asks
well QR codes
ever really take off this question
because of a couple reasons one answers
no not an America - I took the question
because I want to give the vaynernation
the answer to why the early use of QR
codes in America the first time we all
saw them with smartphones
have you ever done a QR code India right
and so you've never done it you've never
done it Stefan have you ever done it for
what yeah got it
so what's interesting to me is it took
off in South Korea and other places
where the early execution the first
10,000 executions of QR codes in that
market brought value it was like you buy
stuff from the subways you could get a
really interesting exclusive content it
was utilitarian it was entertainment in
America marketers ruin everything the
very early QR codes where you take a
shot of the QR code from a branding
standpoint the big mass early stuff that
we saw a half decade ago and it would
show people a YouTube video of the
company's television commercial so the
reason QR codes won't take off is
they've been branded ingrained in our
collective heads as something that
doesn't bring us any value and so when
something establishes itself as not
valuable we don't go back to the well if
email started off as just being spam and
marketing we wouldn't be there and I
would have never involved that first it
was a communication social media it's on
and on and on so QR codes unfortunate
for the QR code gods did not have the
right execution in the US market and the
hill is too big to climb in my opinion
for it to really
take off now look could a queue our
execution come along in the next 24
months that's so incredible and resets
the value prop around it a la snapchat
which they just did it
let's throw up my snapchat QR code so
you can follow me real quick
you know but even that I think was
really significant the hottest app doing
it a lot of us maybe right now it's
bubbling up there will happen so it's
not far-fetched that it has a prayer
based on something like that but in
general my prediction is no and if
somebody does something great we'll
replay this answer and oli crow Matt
asks what's your take on what jay-z is
trying to do what title do you think it
will work Matt what jay-z is doing with
title is what every good entrepreneur
that has brand equity in the consumer
marketplace should be doing which is
leveraging their brand equity to bring
enormous exposure to something that they
disproportionately make more money on
than if they were using somebody else's
thing this is something that should
always be going on with the pseudo
triple-a list celebrities they should
always own they shouldn't be the face of
a cognac or a champagne they should own
it they shouldn't be a face or be on a
platform for music they should own it
whether it's gonna work or not I have no
idea because it's true this for me to
give a really good answer I need to see
the team that's actually executing the
business right just because you're a
big-time star and you bring your big
star x star friends along doesn't mean
the business is gonna succeed what's
what's gonna happen is if the operators
and I I don't know what hope is doing
with his time but I have a feeling you
won't be the CEO of the platform so you
know he's an executor the management
team that's in place is going to
determine its success I had personal
brand equity as a social media voice at
a very small level I'm not even trying
trust me I'm not trying to compare
myself but I was a true triple Z list
celebrity but within a little world that
social media world I had a little equity
and if my management team if I if we
didn't actually do properly we would
have lost there's a lot of people that
use their fame as the match the match to
to make something happen but it all
comes down to the stake the sizzles
there there's exposure we all know what
it is there's a million music services
without a frontman like jay-z and the
other people that we'd never know so
it's got a chance a lot of people check
it out a lot of times it's not as strong
as what's in the marketplace Spotify and
Rdio and all these other things have big
legs up iTunes they all have much longer
time you know so they're further ahead
it's a marathon not a sprint I'm sure
everybody's gonna write it off people
are already writing it off as dead we'll
see what happens over the next 36 to
months but a tremendous lesson for
everybody watching and listening to this
show is it doesn't matter how you start
it matters how you finish right and so
it you know what I'm most curious about
is that there's cynicism around its
success because a lot of famous people
try to put their name on things I look
at jay-z as a uniquely strong
businessman if he's got infrastructure
underneath him or the right players are
in place for title in the next 24 to 48
months it has a chance of doing
something I just don't know what's under
the hood nice I feel deep today
good glad you're excited Sally asks hey
Gary did you decide you wanted to sell
your services to the big fortune 500
companies versus consumers first and
then come up with vaynermedia in other
words did you choose who you wanted to
sell to first to maximize your profits
and then come up with the business model
so this is an interesting question I'm a
very big fan of counterpunching and a
lot of people don't do that a lot of
people lay off business plans they know
what they want to do they go and do it
and they go raise money or they go and
execute and that's how they roll I in
lieu of the tremendous fight this
weekend which it was boring to the
masses but it was a tremendous fight for
me because 13 seconds and I looked at a
jet said this fights over cuz I couldn't
believe how much faster Floyd was than
Pacquiao watching them separately I
thought it'd be closer I knew a second
that he was that much faster the fight
was over because I know what kind of
defensive fighter Floyd is and I'm sure
everybody gets bored and falls asleep
rounds seven through 12 but I'm just
completely like infatuated with boxing
and understood the chess moves that he
was playing out in the ring and enjoyed
that even though I know it's not
commercially rah rah high-energy I view
myself very similar as a businessman I
react I plead it's funny I feel like I'm
on full offense I feel like I'm 48 no
because I play great defense based on
reacting I can react to the market and
adjust the market started coming to me
because I was built writing crush it
putting out videos around business and
amassing a large social media following
and big brands reached out to me and
said hey you've got all these people you
know you know hey we're a fortune 500
company we have 50 followers on Twitter
you have 400,000 followers we've never
heard of you come and teach us come
explain
Plus moments in time AJ was graduating
from bu it was time to do a business
together
we were think about fantasy sports or to
think about other things and so between
timing and being reactionary to the
demand cyclic like responding to the
demand that was in place I was already
playing in the space it wasn't like I
just made something up or there was
demand for me out of left field that
made no sense I was my actions were
setting up my counter punch my actions
were setting up my counter punch I think
it's a very strong model for business
hey Gary I'm dryest neighbors and I'm
doing a 59 week 59 national park road
trip to celebrate the hundredth
anniversary of the National Park Service
I'm quitting my job and I was wondering
how I can use social media to get
sponsorships thank you
the rious you're using social media to
get sponsorship right now right your
actions are leading you to what you want
you hack your way into the show and now
you're on the show and now you've got a
bunch of exposure all the people
watching and listening I thought that
was really clever
I'm sure five to seven of the viewers
also agree that it's clever one of those
five to seven may have a business
proposition but I think the number one
way for you to get sponsorship is to
search terms on Twitter around national
parks and see which businesses are
already engaging by putting out content
or engaging with content around it and
then replying to them in a conversation
not throwing the right hook right away
but saying hey you know your here's a
picture I put on Instagram I think
content Instagram meerkat you know I
think these things matter so I think
it's a heavy level of content putting it
out there and creating some level of
serendipity
I think it's hacking and hustling and
bizdev which you clearly know how to do
because you're now on this show and
getting that exposure I think you reach
out to every other blog that covers
national parks the top 50 big ones and
just pound them into submission there
I'm fine with right hooks in the email
form or hitting them up with social and
then in the cocktail party that is
Twitter engaging with companies that
have money to spend on sponsorships that
are already talking about
counterpunching already that's Floyd's
shoulder thing he does up counter
punching in and engaging with content in
Twitter as it's going on now so that's
that's what I would do
solid advice Andrew asks how will
Instagram evolve in the future you know
everybody took this question without
really even knowing where the heck I'm
going with it because the truth is I'm
not quite sure you know I think that uh
I think one thing's for sure is if
Instagram ever layers Facebook's
targeting capabilities on its platform
to users it would become one of the
great ad products of our time for you
know 2017 16 2017 to 2022 be a two to
four year run there would be incredible
so that's interesting to me will they
use its sister companies data to plug in
their to reach the people I want to
reach if I could reach all wine fans
right now based on Facebook data in an
Instagram photo so that's interesting I
also think that um I also think they'll
be interesting to see if if Instagram
goes into wearables or into more camera
culture there's something about smart
you know smart cameras in a whole
different way than we were even thinking
about it maybe it's here's a good one
what about smart contact lenses like if
I wore contact lenses and if I went it
would take an Instagram photo that's
interesting to me so like how does
Instagram layer into the emerging tech
that a lot of people don't talk about
that's cool and so I'm not quite sure
here's what I do know it has the
attention of the consumer at scale right
now they're doing very subtle changes
they had a product change the other day
right the UI changed a little bit didn't
it was so subtle right like I almost I
noticed it but I didn't hear a headline
about it I noticed it and it didn't stop
me
they in any way I thought that was super
interesting it was a subtle you guys I
see you guys are right it was a subtle
do you like it do you not like it what
did you even think about it is it more
aesthetically pleasing for you yeah I
mean yeah just super subtle right just
knows that we've just evolved right in
our language anyway so Anders hashtag
emojis and they'll you know from what I
know about Kevin Systrom who I respect a
ton and I know lightweight and know a
little bit but I really know more from
afar he's a very thoughtful CEO I think
he cares about the product in the
audience tremendously obviously my first
answer right away into commerce business
you know that's how I roll but I think
he's really
you know consumer first he understands
it needs to stay sticky don't spam it
out don't ruin it I'm interested in the
kind of contact lens thing that I
brought up and some maybe you know
far-fetched far out flexing far out just
some you know just some forward thinking
around the hard something about the
hardware an Instagram makes me excited I
think it's gonna involve passed the
phone and I think that has the potential
to be extremely intriguing I think I'll
make a prediction I don't make
predictions I only react to what's
happening but I'll make one for fun
I think it's program will be a leader in
the next-level hardware version of
photos because I think will happen in
next three or four years and I think
it's rank an hold on to its leadership
yeah it's not the bonus question green
stripes auto ask the very important
question of Star Wars or Star Trek green
stripes Auto I am way I mean I don't
like Star Trek at all and Star Wars is
the only thing that I like in sci-fi I
love the story I grew up on it Empire
Strikes Back 1980 81 82 OSF I've learned
over in 81 right it was an ad camp movie
came out 81 the toys 19 I think for my
sixth birthday with Misha six birthday
coming up at the end of the month this
is kind of an emotional nice thing to
think about which is insane my parents
bought me two Star Wars figures for my
sixth birthday I'm pretty sure firma
that's what it was and I remember
completely beaten being blown away
because we didn't spend money on toys we
were fairly poor still grinding trying
to make our way and I remember being
stunned that they were willing to buy me
two action figures it was a big deal for
me Star Wars was a big part of my six
seven eight year old culture they were
my first kind of toys that we could
afford I was a really like kind of
chaotic kid so I'd lose the lightsabers
immediately I was in toothpick culture
immediately I used to have to use
toothpicks as lightsabers I'm a big fan
Return of the Jedi was something I was
really amped up for because then we
moved to Edison I'd friends 84 super
pumped opening night midnight for when
it came back I'm not even mad at Jar Jar
BIG's things whatever in a big and so uh
I've been into it I'm into the story I'm
very I will definitely go Christmas day
to see the new one and
and I don't like Star Trek at all I
don't think I've never watched any of
the movies I've collected some of the
toys and flipped them but but uh that's
just that eBay culture but I've never
liked that stuff I don't like Star Trek
at all I just like you Star Trek I'm
sorry um and that's that question of the
day what's the question I got one ah so
actually we have to go back and figure
out who got the jerseys right there was
some sure there's plenty right not that
many okay so help me with that
all right and if you actually one tweet
at the Stefon put up this thing here and
help that speed up that pot part and the
number two question of the day both I
need the NBA and the NHL team who will
win the Stanley Cup who'll win the NBA
Finals if somebody gets both right we
will recall that as well
I'm in prize mode a very very okra bout
these days I want to give stuff away
what's going on with the wristbands you
guys are doing it tonight
oh and ek1 on vacation at the right time
and Zach oh that's why he was Owen and
Jesus the doctor anyway wristbands on
the way and you keep asking questions
and I'll keep answering them
already I think Star Trek Star Wars yep